MARTIN OMANDER: Hello, my
name is Martin Omander,
and I welcome you to Google
Root Access, the show featuring
actionable, startup advice.
My guest today is Alex
Haro, cofounder of Life360.
Tell us about your
startup, Alex.
ALEX HARO: Sure,
so first of all,
thank you very much,
Martin, for having me on.
I'm super excited.
Life360 is a mobile
app for families
that lets them stay close and
connected to the people that
matter most in their lives.
Things like seeing where
everyone is on the map,
being able to communicate
throughout the day,
coordinate how they're going
to get together tonight
for dinner, and getting
automated alerts when they
arrive to home, or leave
school, or get to work.
Those are the things we're
focused on, and funny enough,
we're actually one of the
first venture-backed Android
apps ever.
Our first source of funding
was a grant from Google,
when we won the Google Android
competition back in 2008.
And since then,
by really focusing
in on the daily
utility of family life,
and how do we make it
a little bit easier,
we've been able to acquire
a critical mass of 44
million families who are
using us every single day,
and loving the
things that we do.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
So how-- sounds excellent.
How are the numbers?
How is your traction?
ALEX HARO: Sure, I
mean we've already
passed 44 million families,
and we're adding 1 to 2 million
every single month.
And it's growing very
well, and people really
are finding us organically.
We're not paying for
any of those users,
and they're loving us.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Wow, that's amazing.
ALEX HARO: Thank you.
MARTIN OMANDER: So I
downloaded the app myself,
from the Play Store.
ALEX HARO: Awesome.
Count another user, right?
MARTIN OMANDER: One more, yes.
So I didn't have
to pay anything.
How do you guys make money?
ALEX HARO: Sure.
So first of all, the thing that
we're focused in on is scale.
We want to capture the family
network, much like Facebook
has friends and
LinkedIn has work.
No one has really captured
that family network.
And we think it's the real
big, next network to go online.
And so because we're
focused in on that,
we have to build a
compelling product
that users want to
use every single day.
And we do have to provide
something that really provides
utility without forcing
them to pay for it upfront.
That being said,
we eventually do
have to become a legitimate
business that makes money,
and so we've chosen the
freemium model to monetize.
And what we've done is we
have specific features that
are behind a pay wall
that users have to pay,
and those are only
features that they'd
want to use after they're
deeply engaged in Life360
and really finding
the value of it.
So one of our most
popular services
is called LiveAdvisor, who's
a live representative-- you
can think of it like an
OnStar rep in your car--
but for your phone instead.
A live representative
that knows who
you are, where you are,
and can help you out
with things like
a minor emergency,
like a broken down
car, or get you
dinner tickets tonight
for you and your wife.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
So I've had other guests on
this show who have told me--
they've all told
me how hard it is
to get consumers to
pay for something.
And this seems like that's
what you're trying to do.
How's that going?
ALEX HARO: Yeah, I mean,
I'm not going to lie to you.
It definitely is hard.
And there's a whole
bunch of things
that when you're first
thinking about business,
you don't realize how hard it
is actually to get users to pay.
And we launched back
in 2008, and so we
didn't have a lot of these
pay APIs that exist now,
things like in-app
purchase and Paypal,
and all that kind of stuff.
Really weren't mobile
focused at all, back in 2008.
And so when we first launched
our premium offering,
we actually collected
credit cards
straight from the
mobile app itself.
The user had to go in and
provide the full credit card
info, if they were
interested in it.
And surprisingly, that
actually worked for us.
And we actually
had a large number
of users opting into premium,
and loving our premium
services, as well.
But there's a whole
host of issues
that you don't think
about that suddenly pop up
day one, after the
first month of billing.
When all of a sudden, some
percentage of your credit cards
just can't bill.
And we thought we
did something wrong.
It's like, holy
crap, what's wrong?
And it's all things
like lost credit cards,
and people don't, unfortunately,
always have funds,
and cards get stolen,
and cards get fraud,
and they expire over time.
And all these kind of
issues-- a lot of companies
have had to solve,
that have billed
hundreds of millions of
dollars through their systems.
It's very hard for
a small startup
to realize what these
are, and try to solve them
without dedicating
a lot of their time
to billing and billing support.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right, OK.
Yeah that makes
sense, my primary card
has been replaced
twice in the last year.
And I feel sorry
for everybody who
was trying to get money
for my subscriptions.
ALEX HARO: It happens a lot more
frequently than you'd expect,
for sure.
MARTIN OMANDER: So
you go to people--
some people were actually then
entering the full credit card
number, some of them were even
succeeding, and in some cases
you were even able
to charge the card.
But there were
problems, you said.
How did you overcome
these problems?
ALEX HARO: Sure,
so first of all,
I think the reason that
people were able to give us
credit cards, and
felt secure, is
because we are around
family and closed networks,
and our users actually
really do trust us,
and we take that seriously.
And we do a lot of things,
we're PCI compliant,
and we follow all the
appropriate security protocols
and guidelines.
But the way that we
were able to solve it,
and what we've had
great success with,
is actually with Google
In-app purchases.
So about six months
ago, we switched
from doing our own credit card
based solution to Google In-app
purchase, and had great success.
We tripled the
number of conversions
we had every single
day, overnight.
So we released this, and we
went from 1x number of sign-ups
to premium, to 3x overnight.
And it's been awesome.
And the other great
thing about it
is it's a very simple API
that you can build on top of.
Google takes care of all
the really hard details
around how do you re-bill?
How do you send them
emails to make sure
that they enter their
credit card info?
How do you bug them to do it?
How do you remind them?
And how do you deal with fraud
and all that kind of stuff?
Google takes care of all
those kind of details for you,
so you have this very simple
API that you can just say,
hey Google, is this user
still premium or not?
And Google will return yes or
no, and you can deal with that,
and not worry about
all the lower level
details and billing.
MARTIN OMANDER: So the
increased conversion rate,
where does that come
from, do you think?
Is it because people
don't enter the full card?
Or why?
ALEX HARO: So I think
a lot of it is that.
The credit card that you
have on Google Play services,
that is used for Google In-app,
is for all of your apps.
So say you love "Angry Birds,"
and you want to upgrade,
for whatever the upgrade
for "Angry Birds"
is, and you enter
your credit card.
Or say you really love
Life360, and you're
willing to put your
credit card in for that.
Once you enter your credit
card, then it's in the system,
and it's available to
all the other apps.
So after you've gone
through that experience,
say you've done it for "Angry
Birds," now you love Life360,
you're using every
single day, you say,
hey, I want to upgrade for
some of these premium features.
It's a one-click check out.
So you just click and say,
yes, I want to buy this.
And all of a sudden, that's it.
So there's no more of this
having to enter your credit
card details every time,
and a lot of people
haven't even memorized
their credit card,
so they have to pull it out
and they may be driving,
or something crazy like that.
Instead, it's just
one-click touch,
and you automatically upgrade.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
So Google takes
a cut, of course.
That's on one side
of the equation.
On the other side of the
question is greater conversion
rate you mentioned
that you've seen.
How were you thinking
about that trade off?
Is it worth it?
Is it barely worth it to you?
ALEX HARO: Sure, absolutely.
I mean, obviously this is
very specific on everyone's
business, but what we've seen
is for our premium offering,
some of it it's digital, some
of it's real, hard costs--
but the relative fixed cost per
premium user is relatively low.
And so when we look at
the cost of developer time
to figure out all these
billing issues, when
we think about the cost of how
do we acquire these new premium
offerings, when we think about
just like going from 1x to 3x,
that's almost worth it itself.
All of those costs add up.
They may not be
30%, but you end up
making more money--
we definitely
have-- through Google
In-app, then when you
try to do it yourself.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
So finally what is your
advice to other startups
who are trying to bill consumers
on a subscription model?
ALEX HARO: Sure.
So I think one of the things
that everyone needs to focus in
on is build something
that users really want.
I think that's where we've
been hugely successful,
we've actually built something
that users really want.
And then you'll figure
out how to build them
and how to pay them,
but unless you're really
building that product that
users really want to pay for,
anything else will be trickery.
Like the users
have to want to pay
before you'll get them to pay.
So first and foremost,
focus on making a product
that users really
do want to pay for.
Then when it comes to
actually billing them,
don't try to solve
the problems yourself.
You'll spend far too
much time figuring out,
how does American Express trade
against Visa and MasterCard?
And how do I re-bill users?
And all sorts of things that
many other people have spent
many other people's
times figuring it out.
And you should be focused
on building your product,
not figuring out
how to bill users.
Whether it's In-app,
or some other service,
you really should consider using
another service that really
knows how to bill
users and how to deal
with all these
credit card issues.
And you just worry on
building your awesome product
the users do want to pay for.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great--
great advice, Alex.
Thank you for sharing
your experiences with us.
ALEX HARO: Absolutely, and
thank you for having me here.
MARTIN OMANDER: We hope
you found something
you can use in your startup.
Your input matters.
Please leave your
comments below.
We read everything you write.
To learn how Google
can help your startup,
go to
developers.google.com/startup.
If you would like to
be a guest on the show,
go to bit.ly/applyrootaccess.
That's it for now.
See you next time.